or ukrainians are being told to switch
off their electricity from seven this
morning to 11 this evening it's in
response to Russia's widening strikes
against energy facilities the National
Grid operator says the curb is limited
to Thursday but more restrictions and
blackouts may be needed with winter
approaching
for many ukrainians though the
eight-month War has already meant living
without power Heats or running water
preparing dinner in a makeshift outdoor
kitchen nine-year-old artem and his
grandma Arena are hurrying to get dinner
ready before the Setting Sun plunges
their home into cold and darkness
it's really cold
I'm sleeping in my clothes in my
apartment now
you sure
Russian strikes have cut off Utilities
in cities and towns across Ukraine and
many residents here in the khakib region
have been living without gas water or
electricity for weeks now
our windows were damaged
now we are only eating here but sleeping
in the next apartment because their
windows are not damaged so it's warmer
there
for many people bundling up at night and
cooking Outdoors is a matter of survival
could go through the situations like
this no electricity no water no gas
we're cold you can see we're building
fires
Anton lives with his mother
she's disabled and is totally dependent
on her son's help it's a problem it's
really cold now if it weren't for my son
I would freeze
the homes of residents living in
villages like these in the khachif
region have been thrust into a
pre-industrial ERA with no modern
comforts
authorities are trying to reassure
people that electricity will be restored
soon and that repairs to water and gas
infrastructure will come next
but with the war and with absolutely no
certainty
people like artem and his grandmother
can only prepare for what will likely be
a very harsh Ukrainian winter
let's get an update on the war in
Ukraine with Matthias Berliner he's in
Kiev I believe there has been some
movement as far as Ukraine's military
goes tightening the news around Russian
forces around Hassan could you tell us
more there
we don't have any uh confirmed uh uh
advances yet but fighting is going on
there and we've seen some signs in the
past few days that uh it does not look
very good for the Russian occupational
troops there uh the command uh the
commander for the for the Ukraine the
Russian Commander for Ukraine has said
it's very difficult
authorities have started to they call it
evacuate people from these areas but
there is the suspicion that these might
be forced movements that these might be
deportations we don't have any definite
information on that
um and uh British intelligence assumes
that Russia might be retreating from the
city of Hassan this would be of course a
major development being the only
administrative Center that Russia has
been able to capture in the beginning of
the war I think the next days would
bring a very interesting news there
um at the same time you listened in to
the German Chancellor's policy speech
Just earlier uh with me is it
disappointing from where you're standing
to hear that the EU does have the funds
to fight its energy crisis uh that
Germany does continue to support Ukraine
but doesn't have anything concrete uh to
to promise the ukrainians in in this
urgent time of need
yeah basically shows has reiterated what
he has been saying and doing before has
listed all the things he's done in the
past there was
a a new specific announcement of
training that that was from this week
training of Ukrainian soldiers in the EU
but overall he's not made any
announcements now I think the good thing
is that governments have ways to talk to
each other besides public speeches and
that the more important information will
be conveyed in bilateral speeches so we
do not know whether anything is in the
making but for now Charles has really
not announced anything there's really
nothing new in this speech with concerns
to uh uh the support of Ukraine
militarily or financially he said it
that Germany will continue but no new
announcements Matthias how urgent would
you say that
ukrainians need help and need more help
right now as far as things go on the
battlefield
well there's what for one thing there's
the issue of the tanks so that Ukraine
wants modern Western tanks to uh that
would be used in these advances as in
her son as we've been talking about
um but the what the past two weeks with
these massive attacks on infrastructure
have shown that is that Ukraine needs
better air defenses Germany has started
delivering air defense systems to
Ukraine the IRS T is considered one of
the most advanced systems that can hit
planes Rockets Etc but with these new
drones there are also other needs now
the Drone stiff fly lower they're harder
to catch they can fly zigzag they're
harder to be spotted by Raiders etc etc
and there are systems for that and there
are German manufacturers factories are
producing uh these these kind of systems
there are also others Swedish South
Korean Israeli we're hearing
um but uh this was certainly something
that Ukraine would want from Germany and
that probably talks will go on about we
have heard nothing about it we've just
heard from sources that this is
something that Ukraine wishes to have
but it might be easier for Germany to
make a move on that than on the tanks
which seem to carry a very symbolic
meaning for Charles and and for the SPD
in in the government German battle tanks
against Russian tanks this is not the
same case for air defenses so let's
watch what will come out of these talks
and also the question on how quickly
these can be produced the German
military industry hasn't been uh very
productive hasn't been outputting a lot
in the past 30 years because demand
wasn't that high so it might also take
some time for any system to be delivered
DW's Matthias Berlinger in Kiev
following a war in Ukraine thank you
very much
Russian president
four regions of Ukraine that Moscow
illegally annexed after a series of
discredited votes just weeks ago
kremlin-backed officials in her son one
of those regions announced it would move
civilians out of the area ahead of an
expected Ukrainian offensive a step that
could amount to force deportation
Herson was one of the first Ukrainian
cities to fall to Russian forces now
Ukraine is preparing to retake control
these images by a Russian and sold
official claimed to show fortifications
outside the city as Russian forces are
retreating from her son Vladimir Putin
blames Ukraine for defending its
territory
the cave regime refused to recognize the
will of the people reject any proposals
for negotiation
as gunfire continues civilians die
Putin declared martial law and the four
Ukrainian regions that Moscow illegally
annexed
we're working on solving very complex
large-scale tasks to ensure security and
protect the future of Russia to protect
our people
the move was seen as a clear response to
recent military setbacks as Ukraine
counter-offensive advances
the situation in the area of the special
military operation can be described as
tense the enemy is not abandoning its
attempts to attack Russian forces
our further actions and plans regarding
the city of Hassan itself will depend on
the military and tactical situation I
repeat
it is already very difficult as of today
Putin's decree came on the day that
Russian installed officials in the
Ukrainian city of Herson announced they
would move civilians in anticipation of
an imminent Ukrainian attack
and we can now speak to investigative
journalists and writer Catherine Belton
she works for the Washington Post and
she is the author of the 2020 book
Putin's people MS Belton welcome to DW
what do you make of Putin declaring
martial law in the annex territories
what's his strategy here
um he's obviously very worried about
this Ukrainian counter-offensive uh it
does look like they're very very close
notes taking her son and he's sort of
making steps to make it clear to his
population that this is Ukraine's
aggression not Russia's aggression and
in fact an advisor to the defense
Ministry has said that he's worried that
what the Russians are doing are
preparing the ground uh for a kind of a
misinformation campaign he's worried
that this evacuation is preparing the
ground for some kind of bombing attack
which then the Russians could blame on
the ukrainians
um so there's all kinds of shuffling
going on but really uh the bottom line
is the loss of her son for Putin is
going to be a very big blow every move
Putin makes is a further escalation it
seems is he just digging a deeper and
deeper hole for himself or can he
actually turn the tide of the war
you know it's very difficult obviously
he's already been backed into uh forcing
uh the mobilization of his own people
he'd always promised that he was never
going to have to do that it's a deeply
unpopular step which really underlines
the foundations of his own presidency
his legitimacy as president is based on
his popularity and really by bringing
the war home to Russians now uh bringing
it not it's not like it was popular
among Russians because they were
watching almost as if they were watching
a football match on TV but now they're
risking the lives of their loved ones uh
people who might not come back uh from
the front who are going to be barely
trained and equipped to fight the
ukrainians and and really uh he never
won it was a measure that he never
wanted to take and it's already leaving
him very vulnerable to criticism within
his Elite and by declaring martial law
Putin is also in a way admitting that
Russia is in fact at War something that
he's trying to avoid until now by
labeling it a special military operation
hasn't he what could be the domestic
repercussions of this
you know I think I mean with each stage
over the past month as Russia has lost
more and more territory to the
ukrainians uh Putin is sort of preparing
the ground it seems for this recognition
of what he's called a special military
operation as a war first you have the
mobilization now the martial law in
these Ukrainian regions in a kind of a a
semi-uh martial law status even within
Uh Russian regions itself on the borders
of Ukraine whether it's going to be
stricter laws enforced an economic
mobilization to support the effort so
all the while it's creeping closer and
closer to that and and really uh just
having a big impact on his uh standing
in the elite and among the population
there was a recent opinion poll by uh
the Kremlin link public opinion
Foundation which found that uh 70 of
Russians are now very very anxious about
what's going on uh he's really bringing
bringing the the city situation home to
ordinary Russians so I think his
position is is much more precarious than
it's ever been in his entire presidency
who is still on board with this war you
wrote a book called Putin's people who
are Putin's people at this stage
you know uh we're seeing divisions
emerge uh within the elite around him of
course there are hardliners who are
pressing uh Putin to act ever harder
against Ukraine uh I mean he himself or
sees this war that he began almost by
accident because he believed that uh you
know at the first sight of Russian
troops uh president zielinski of recline
would just run away I didn't think he
ever envisioned the envisaged that eight
months on he'd still be fighting this
war but it has gone on he's backed into
a corner so there are hardliners such as
uh Evgeni pregosian uh he's a long time
Ally of his from Saint Petersburg who
has sent his own mercenaries into fight
in Ukraine uh there's another book
called Nikolai Patricia who is the head
of uh Russian Security Council who was
very instrumental in in Paving the way
towards this war in Ukraine he told
Putin uh just days before it and now
Infamous security council meeting that
the U.S was using Ukraine as a platform
to destabilize Russia and undermine it
and he told Putin that we our task is to
defend Russia's sovereignty and
territorial Integrity
um so he's pretty much telling including
what to do and so he's definitely a hawk
but there are definitely those within
Russia's economic Elite now who are
becoming more and more aghast at what's
going on uh in the summer they were
perhaps content to let the war rumble on
in East Ukraine uh they were hoping to
divert trade flows through China and
India uh in an avoidance of Western
sanctions but that's becoming ever more
difficult and they're seeing Putin lose
territory and that's not just uh a loss
to his popularity it's it's kind of a
loss to his standing within the elite
and suddenly he is becoming play a game
yeah Putin has been going to Great
Lengths to place the blame for Russian
defeats on his defense minister but he
is the commander-in-chief of the Russian
Armed Forces so our people starting to
point fingers at him
well we've seen some reporting out of
the U.S I think from some some
colleagues who said that Al Putin had
was personally taking command of the
army that he was actually issuing orders
himself uh trying to sort of kind of
embeigle himself into the day-to-day
operations so at some point uh it is
going to come back to invite him I mean
so far most of the criticism has been
directed at his military Chiefs but uh I
think that's getting harder and harder
to keep a lid on especially as we see
this constant retreat Catherine Belton
investigative journalist and writer
pleasure speaking to you tonight
thank you so much